stars are just like us nowhere near
indestructible while shooting a TV show
can be a relatively cushy job it can
also sometimes be dangerous and
potentially even fatal here are some
actors who were almost killed due to
stunts gone wrong crew carelessness or
their own near deadly mistakes
Matthew Fox while filming a scene for
the final episode of Lost in 2010 star
Matthew Fox nearly lost his life
according to co-star Jorge Garcia who
recounted the ordeal on his podcast
about the final season in the show's
finale Fox's Jack and Terry O'Quinn's
Locke fight on a cliff and at one point
locked stabs Jack the show's creative
team didn't think a collapsible stunt
knife looked convincing on camera so
they filmed all the fighting with a real
knife and planned to use the collapsible
one only to film the stabbing but they
forgot to swap out the knives when it
came time to shoot the scene and during
one take O'Quinn accidentally started to
stab fox with the real deal
fortunately Fox took the stunt
coordinators advice and wore protective
Kevlar under his shirt
which likely saved his life Mariska
Hargitay actress Mariska Hargitay prides
herself on doing her own stunts on NBC's
long-running police procedural Law and
Order SVU and for about ten years
Hargitay did so without incident until
October 2008 when she fell wrong while
trying to execute a stunt more
accurately she jumped landed wrong and
fell in such a way that she damaged a
lung leading to a microscopic bleed over
the course of the next three months
her lungs slowly started collapsing and
she eventually required multiple
surgeries to repair her lung and reverse
the potentially life-threatening
condition
kristen chenoweth in the summer of 2012
actress Kristin Chenoweth was filming
scenes for what was supposed to be a
guest starring arc on the CBS legal
drama The Good Wife but a freak accident
ended those plans and almost killed her
a piece of the lighting rig came loose
and fell right on her face knocking her
unconscious I was just standing there
with my prop phone and I just remember
saying oh this phone is that's all I
remember when she woke up later in the
hospital she learned that she'd
fractured her skull and injured her hip
and a rib two years later she was still
in physical therapy to recover from the
accident Dominic Purcell in early 2016
Dominic Purcell was filming scenes in
Morocco for
revival of prison-break in a bizarre
turn of events a piece of the set broke
free and fell right on top of the actors
head blood was just pouring all over me
and then my stunt guy came up to me and
he said well here's the thing it's cut
open and I could see your skull Purcell
suffered a broken nose and a minor head
injury but the show must go on shooting
continued as Purcell was airlifted to a
large Hospital in Casablanca not long
after the accident Purcell reassured
fans on his Instagram page pays to have
a thick skull when an iron bar falls on
your head the Brady Bunch
in 1973 the Brady Bunch filmed at the
Kings Island amusement park in Mason
Ohio in the episode the plan was to have
the Bradys take a ride on the red racer
roller coaster to get the shot the
producers wanted to put a camera
operator in the front car of the coaster
to catch the actors real reactions Brady
Bunch creator Sherwood Schwartz ordered
a test run of the coaster with just a
camera mounted on the front car no
camera operator and no Brady's the
camera was too high and hit an overhang
during the tests were at the real deal
the camera operator would have been
struck as well and the ride could have
been deadly for him and the Bradys
ultimately the camera was rigged in a
lower safer spot in the scene was filmed
without a hitch Aaron Paul in the DVD
commentary for the first season of
Breaking Bad Aaron Paul revealed that he
was almost killed while shooting a scene
in the desert in front of the show's RV
/ mobile meth lab Paul adjusted his
blocking while filming with co-star
Bryan Cranston moving a few steps away
from where a massive rock later fell
from on top of the RV turns out there
was a tarp on top of the RV held in
place by the rock and the rock was
dislodged by a strong gust of wind a
show creator Vince Gilligan notes a 40
pound rock falling 14 feet on top of
Paul could have killed him if it wasn't
for the last-minute adjustment BAM I'm
like what the hell you know thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel + check
out all this cool stuff we know you'll
love -
[Music]